lo que quiero hacer es mostrarles la
gráfica de esta función
fx que esencialmente está compuesta por
segmentos de recta y tratar de
determinar cuál es la gráfica de la
derivada de esta función
fx muy bien entonces estos picos ya te
estarán diciendo que va a haber
discontinuidades en la derivada es decir
en esos lugares no va a ser derivar
derivable así que vamos a tratar de
verlos vamos a tratar de verlo y lo
primero es que cuál es la la pendiente
de la recta tangente en este segmento
por ejemplo pues esencialmente como el
segmento la recta tangente coincide con
ella misma así que basta calcular la
pendiente de esta recta de este segmento
entonces como sabemos calcularlo es el
cambio en jay dividido entre el cambio
en x cuanto avanza y bueno por más bien
avanzamos 2 en x y avanzamos 1 en que
avanzamos 2 en x y avanzamos 1 y
entonces avanzamos 2 en x y avanzamos 1
y entonces la derivada o la pendiente de
esta recta
un medio así que vamos a tratar de
seleccionar de estas cuatro opciones
cual conviene así que esta es una opción
la a y la c porque aquí estamos en un
medio verdad aquí está un medio sin
embargo en bay en de no porque aquí en
digamos desde menos cuatro hasta menos
dos nos está diciendo que la pendiente
es 1 y no es cierto era un medio
aquí nos está diciendo que es menos
menos un medio así que ésta tampoco
puede ser sólo nos queda a jose muy bien
ahora bien la pendiente entre -2 y aquí
estamos en 1 vale simplemente 0 verdad
tenemos una recta horizontal y eso
coincide muy bien con lo que nos está
diciendo a hice que justo entre -2 y 1
vale 0 vamos a ver qué pasa al final
vamos a ver qué pasa al final aquí
tenemos que cada vez que bajamos 12 ya
avanzamos 1 en x cada vez que bajamos 2
d y avanzamos 1 en x así que nuestro
cambio en y entre el cambio en x es
bajar
2 / 1 que es menos 2 y si coincide
verdad que justo entre 1 y digamos
infinito quizás la derivada es menos 2
menos 2 ahora tú ya lo mejor ya podrás
ver cuál de estas dos es la correcta y
esencialmente es por lo que dije al
inicio del vídeo dijimos que en estos
puntos la derivada no está definida en
menos dos y en uno que sería justo en
estos saltos en la gráfica de la
derivada no está definida porque si nos
aproximamos por la izquierda vale un
medio y si nos aproximamos por la
derecha pues vale cero entonces en este
punto no está definido así que aquí nos
está diciendo que en realidad vale menos
un medio y no es cierto verdad
cuando rellenan estas bolitas nos están
indicando que este es el valor de la
derivada y aquí nos están diciendo que
no está definida no está definido el
valor de la derivada así que si alguno
hay que elegir no va a ser a si no va a
ser
en la opción c